welcome to the second part of the basic
modeling and simulation tutorial in this
part we'll go over how to use
drag-and-drop to create models in
Wolfram system obler as lost time
these instructions that I have here will
be distributed in the chat window so you
can follow along for yourself
we'll start by reusing ready-made
glosses insist the modeler as a starting
point for our new model the first we'll
learn how to find classes in the class
browser then we'll make a copy of the
class and finally we'll learn how to
save your copy how it to save your new
model then we'll customise the model by
adding new connections and components to
the model will change parameters and
will learn how to add completely new
parameters to the model
lastly we'll simulate this custom class
we'll learn how to set experiment
settings and simulation settings and how
to add plots that will be displayed upon
simulation
I will start by opening up a new session
of system modeler firstly we'll locate
the inverted pendulum model inside of
the introductory shot samples systems
sub package
in this tutorial we'll construct a model
of a DC motor if you recall from the
previous tutorial the inverted pendulum
model already had a DC motor component
you can see it here in the diagram view
a component is an instance of a model
you can find the definition of a certain
component by right-clicking it and
selecting go to close in close browser
in the close browser packages will be
expanded to reveal the modeling question
just like the runnable inverted pendulum
model the electrical motor model can be
opened by double-clicking it in the
class browser this will be a good
starting point for your own DC motor
however if you try and change anything
in the model for example trying to move
or delete a component you will not be
able to all built-in models in system
modeler are read-only and this will be
indicated in the box in the top right
corner of the diagram view the reason
for this is that changing the definition
of the electric motor model here will
change all the models that utilize it as
a component
you can still reuse the model however to
do this you need to create a copy of the
electrical motor model right-click
electrical motor in the class browser
and select duplicate alternatively you
can press control D on Windows or Linux
or command D on Mac OS a dialog window
will ask you if you want to rename the
cloth check the box next to rename copy
and type in DC motor then press ok the
copied model will open in the diagram
you notice the grid lines behind the
model the presence or absence of
gridlines is one of the easiest ways to
tell if a model is modifiable or not
now instead of read-only the box in the
top right of the diagram you will say
unsaved to save a model with it opened
in the diagram view press control s on
Windows and Linux or command s on Mac OS
you'll be prompted to select the
location in which to save your model by
mandelic convention the file should have
the same name as the model followed by
the extension mo
by now you should have opened three
different models in model center when
you open up a new model the old mold
stays in a separate tab you can go ahead
and close the inverted pendulum and
electrical motor models as we won't be
revisiting them in this tutorial either
press the X button next to each of them
or right-click the DC motor tab and
select close all but this using the
motor model a starting point you'll now
add your own components to modify the
motor on the left and right side or
connectors meant for making outside
connections to other components in this
tutorial you'll make a self-contained
model and you can start by removing the
blue and white connection component to
remove a component select it by clicking
it and press Delete
the next step is to add a new component
to the diagram in this tutorial we'll be
using components from the Metallica
standard library this library can be
found under the libraries tab in the
class browser
you can expand a library in the same way
as you did with the example packages by
clicking the arrow next to the icon a
signal source is needed to set the
voltage over the circuit a range of
signal sources can be found in the block
sub library on the sources the ramp
model produces a ramping signal and will
be a good fit for your DC motor model to
add the ramp model as a component to
your diagram click it in the class
browser and drag it into the diagram
once on the diagram you can let go off
the mouse button and the component will
be placed after the component has been
placed you can move it around on the
diagram by dragging it around the next
step is to connect the output of the
ramp component to the input of the
voltage source to do this switch the
connection line tool by clicking the
connection line tool icon in the toolbar
or by pressing C on your keyboard with
the connection line tool first click the
small triangle indicating the output
from the ramp then click the filled
large triangle indicating the input to
the voltage source a line will be drawn
between them indicating that a
connection has been made next it is time
to add something for the motor to drive
on the right side of the motor add an
inertia component since the motor is
producing a mechanical rotational motion
you'll find this component under the
mechanics rotational in components sub
libraries add an inertia component to
the diagram like you previously did with
a wrap and connect it to the white
circle on the motor component
when adding new components to the
diagram they will often have some
default values for their parameters
typically 0 or 1 in whatever default
unit it is you will now change this to
your own parameter values if you select
a component by clicking it a parameter
term will be shown in the bottle bottom
of model Center
greyed-out numbers indicate the default
parameter values
in the field labeled duration type in
five to indicate that it shall take five
seconds for the ramp to reach its
maximum value next to start type type in
1 the next step is to set the moment of
inertia on the motor load you might have
noticed that the parameters that appear
in the parameter tab when no component
is selected these are associated with a
model rather than any particular
component you can add your own
parameters to the top view by
right-clicking in the parameters tab and
selecting insert parameters you'll get a
new dialog that allows you to add
parameters to your model to use the
correct unit for your new parameter
check the radio button next to SI unit
and scroll down to inertia
to search faster you can start typing
inertia on your keyboard
in the name field type in J to give the
parameter a name next to the description
field give it a descriptive text such as
moment of inertia on the motor load
leave the value field blank for now
press add to add the new parameter to
the parameters tab then close the window
by pressing close if you made any
mistakes you can at any time bring back
up the parameter dialog by clicking on
the blue J now you can have a value for
the moment of inertia by typing it in
the field next to the parameter since
you selected a unit for the parameter
you can select between different
prefixes for the inertial unit
click on kilograms times square meters
and select kilograms times square
centimeters in this tutorial you'll use
a very light load on the motor
typing 1 in the input field we haven't
actually used the parameter on the motor
load yet to do that select the inertia
component and type in J in the field
next to the parameter J now whenever you
change the value on the top-level
parameter the parameter in the component
will be changed as well collecting
important parameters in the top-level
makes it easier to change them it also
means that you can reuse them in
multiple places across your model since
you've made your own your modifications
to original model it is a good idea to
check that everything seems everything
can connect it correctly
press the validate close button to check
this
when clicked system Allah will count the
number of variables and the number of
equations for a model to be valid every
variable needs to be able to be
described for one equation if you follow
all the steps correctly you should see
the following since there are as many
variables as there are equations the
model is globally balanced press the
play button to start the simulation once
you do the following window will pop-up
since this is a completely new model
there are no experiment settings the
tell simulation center how long the
simulation should run for you can set
this by clicking on review settings the
default option is to simulate for 10
seconds change this to a hundred seconds
in order to give the motor a bit more
time to reach steady state when you
press ok the model will be simulated
unlike the previous tutorial upon
simulation no plot will be immediately
shown if you're continuing straight from
the previous tutorial you might have one
or more simulation tabs open already
to avoid confusion go ahead and close
them by right-clicking one of the tabs
and selecting close all
you can also go ahead and close the
previous experiments right-click the DC
motor tab and select close all but this
next make a plot of the angular velocity
of the motor this can be found by
expanding the EMF one component and
plotting the variable called W this plot
can be particularly useful for
understanding the system Xi's should
save it to the model right click in the
plot window and select add plot to model
give it a descriptive names such as
motor speed and check the box next to
the preferred plot option in order to
display it immediately upon simulation
go ahead and add another plot to the
model click the new plot tab button from
the toolbar to add a blank tap then plot
the voltages over the EMF one resistor
and voltage source components each
variable called V
you
also add a new subplot and plot plot the
current running through their circuit
for example by plotting the variable I
on the EMF one
you
like the motor speed plot add this new
plot to the model and give it a
descriptive name such as circuit voltage
and current
with the custom plot added we've reached
the end of this tutorial before I leave
you I'd like to reiterate the things
that we've learned in this part we've
learned how to reuse ready-made classes
how to duplicate them and how to
customize them by adding our own
components in Connexions as well as our
own parameters lost lis we learnt how to
simulate the model and set up custom
experiment settings and adding and by
adding new plots to the model with this
part being done we'll open it up to
questions from from you before moving it
on to the last part which will deal with
how to find different components inside
of system modeler
you